cine mayor contratiempo en temas de
seguridad como ya lo había dicho el jefe
de la policía del capitolio tom meijer
bailén acusó usted lo decía el ex
presidente de honor de expandir una
mentira sobre el supuesto fraude
electoral sin entregar ninguna prueba a
lo que el ex presidente de donald trump
respondió diciendo que tanto acto de
conmemoración en esta jornada
simplemente era un teatro para ocultar
el fracaso del gobierno de joe by de
nancy pelosi conmemoró la muerte de los
cuatro policías que murieron defendiendo
el capitolio hace un año y la jornada
concluyó con una vigilia a las afueras
del capitolio donde se prendieron velas
y se hicieron oraciones hay que recordar
que el fiscal general eric hablando ha
dicho que las investigaciones sobre lo
que pasó hace un año seguirán hasta las
últimas consecuencias y hasta el momento
hay
725 personas que han sido acusadas y
arrestadas por la toma al capitolio
precisamente el 6 de enero del 2021
cristóbal a un año de lo sucedido qué
opinan los estadounidenses de su
democracia y de la estabilidad de su
gobierno
si es de resaltar una encuesta que hizo
acción su medio digital en eeuu donde
resalta que el 70 por ciento de los
demócratas encuestados cree que un acto
así un acto de violencia así como que él
como el que pasó hace un año puede
volver a pasar pronto el 37% de los
encuestados dice que ya no tiene fe en
la democracia estadounidense después de
lo que pasó hace un año y el 40% de los
estadounidenses sigue creyendo que hubo
fraude electoral sólo el 55 por ciento
de los encuestados dice que el joven
ganó las elecciones legítimamente eso
quiere decir que el país sigue bastante
polarizado después de un año de lo que
ocurrió aquí en el capitolio